there isn't any type of waste that can't
be reinvented and I'm here to prove it I
got something for you so Oreo has
challenged us to fix cookie wrappers and
make something from it was there any
cookies to eat yet whoa what we have
here from the material strengths
perspective is we have this plastic
entirely not recyclable hundreds of
millions of these are ending up in a
landfill in America every year dinosaurs
will be back you think the dinosaurs
will be back before these all around his
body becomes the Themis before before we
get into specific products let's let's
figure out what all the features are you
know what yeah yeah see you can you guys
pull it apart it's strong we'll do a ton
of are you ready 123
good where you Lou we just figured out
it's extremely strong right it's also
waterproof we know that we need a
product we're gonna make and pull off in
a huge way you can make pain pens pens
pencils really even like notebooks I'll
make a bell first right now okay right
there a phone in your eyes that way you
can you know pick up hitting girls I
think I've seen homeless people with
that style yeah come on no balance
nobody any good you're you're kicking
off the island man let's make something
real looking fly slip and slide laughs
two layers that would be so much fun I'm
actually be honest my favorite idea is
the poncho Dean can we see it here you
go my friend I mean obviously we'd have
to fuse it together it's like Pancho via
do the honors I like the poncho how
about a car you like height I'm gonna
tell you what a shower curtain showers
oh there you go that's waterproof what
if I made a hot air balloon yeah well
more will want that lunch box lunch
messenger bag what do you guys think out
of all these let's pick between like
height birthday hat placemats what do
you guys think hey I'm hearing kaireekea
needs a kite can be interesting to see
how that works okay
it's like that one we're gonna bring new
meaning to the saying go fly a kite